so this is what happens when a 52 year
old decides to attack
uh and go at a guy in jake paul who
literally
has
the youtube social media world by the
[ __ ] balls
so dana's video dana's video is it's
like you know if my dad facetime they're
like i don't need to see up your nose so
it's like a bad lighting he's clearly
like in his mansion whatever it's just
bad lighting
he and he doesn't address anything that
jake asks for right so it's like he's
kind of rambling a little bit
and then jake goes he's off seeing saint
barts of partying for new year's and
someone tells him dan [ __ ] is what he
ha he shoots this video sends it to his
team who all they do is make content and
cut and create
and
literally just
directs dana white in this because he's
using graphics and references and edits
him saying i use cocaine it's like this
is a 10-6 round for jake paul man easily
easily